[Music]
[Applause]
Molly I just saw Ryan Leaf uh walk by
yeah our buddy just popped in the studio
oh see if Ryan wants to join us oh
please yeah maybe uh he can sit in your
chair there former uh quarterback done
some great stuff I saw him on NFL uh the
NFL Network he did some stuff there he
is
here look at that how about that is he
in our tournament how am I doing I just
had to drop my car off at the Kia of
Milford so I thought I'd come over and
sit for the two hours and watch your
show and then he asked me to come work
okay yeah all right well great to see
you uh the NFL Network I've seen you on
the uh doing the morning thing yeah it's
been a lot of fun
um you know they've given me an
opportunity to break down some players
and then uh last week I got to host the
whole show for three days while Peter
Schrager was at the at the combine so
that was that was a lot of fun you
brought up something and I'm gonna get
to this other situation with Lamar
Jackson and Aaron Rodgers but you
brought up something about Russell
Wilson and why he's been struggling and
I'd not heard that from anybody so if
you could Enlighten our audience on what
you think could be maybe at the Crux of
Russ struggling in Denver well I I
didn't mean for any it to be an excuse
or anything it's not I just don't think
enough people had context around what
happened so
um when he got to IMG before he started
to go into the draft he met a young man
by the name of Trevor Moab and Trevor
worked really in the cognitive thinking
um Behavior aspect of things uh he's
worked with Alabama and Nick Saban and
Kirby Smart in Georgia for years helping
them players build this mentality and
and uh he really worked with with
Russell and Russell bought into it hook
line and sinker uh it's a neutral
thinking it is about not allowing uh a
semblance of negativity into your
thinking at all it's not necessarily
positive thinking it's just staying as
neutral as possible
um and and I think it's and he bought
into it so much that it almost seems at
times like he he's a simulation
sometimes yes and and so that can be
off-putting that could be isolating
um
but Trevor who
helped me once I got out of prison
started working with me away the way I
think in the way I go about things and
he's re a big reason why I'm I'm the
person I am right now
in these last 10 years
um he passed away
unfortunately uh right at the end of of
Russell's tenure in in Seattle and they
usually did their work in the off season
so they probably had all their work kind
of done and and and ready to go that
year and and he struggled of courses
last year in Seattle with injuries and I
I just think it was something
that truly affected him last year I
think he just went so much over the top
to try to be that way it did look like
he was a simulation at times last year
and um and I had some friends of his
reach out here after they saw me talk
about it and said this was kind of spot
on and and you're right no one was
talking about this everybody was kind of
I get people throwing trash at them
around everything and some of the things
he's done but I wanted some people to
have some context around and it was also
a way to honor my friend who's who's
gone who did tremendous things for so
many people for Russell in particular uh
and for me in particular as well yeah
we've had we had Trevor in here he
joined us uh one show and you know
talked about positivity and talked about
you know being with athletes and and how
you get them ready for an upcoming
season or a big game Ryan Leaf joining
us uh by surprise here in studio the
Lamar Jackson situation
how does this work out
for both
I I mean I don't see how it does but
then to hear the teams last night just
instantaneously come out and say well
we're not we're not in the Lamar Jackson
business
especially especially teams that we are
talking about need quarterback but you
think they're saying that and that's the
way they're going to be this entire
summer or do you think the Falcons go
you know listen to this anybody yeah
listen to this so I when I was on
Governor football the other morning I
said anything you hear from Super Bowl
to draft day you can't believe a word
that comes out of anybody's mouth
nobody's not an agents not a players not
a front office anybody because
everybody's trying to leverage everybody
everybody's trying to get something more
off somebody so yeah I I don't like the
the public aspect of it or they came out
and did that maybe they were posturing
because I don't
I can't fathom a bunch of teams going
after Lamar Jackson right now because
you can get him by paying him what he
wants and all you have to give up is two
first round draft picks
I I I'm I'm all in that that thing if
I'm the Jets if I'm the Panthers if I'm
the Falcons yeah but are you paying him
230 million dollars guarantee you are
yes
yes this is where contracts are going
and this is why no one wants to do it
because they don't want a second they
can use the DeSean Watson as an outlier
because of the significant difference of
what was going on last year they don't
want to pay a second one because then
owners throughout the league now know
every time they sign a quarterback it's
gonna have to be fully guaranteed money
but I know they're trying to reset the
market yeah but I would be saying to
Lamar and his mom we're going to look at
Kyler Murray and Russell Wilson's
contract like that's that's where we can
be and we want you to be here and we
will guarantee you know you'll get the
same numbers that they're getting
and you know is that going to be good
enough for you or do you just say no I
should be paid every bit what DeSean
Watson's getting paid he uh he is stuck
to his guns and I will I'll give him a
ton of credit for that because I don't
think for a second that if there isn't a
contract that comes on the table and
he's asked to play on the non-exclusive
tag next year I don't think he plays on
it either but I got to give up two first
round picks for him and pay him all that
money I think Atlanta would be an ideal
place for him I could see the commanders
and Daniel Snyder given the middle
finger to the rest of the NFL and say
hey before I sell this team I'm going to
give him that you guys deal with that uh
yeah you guys deal with that when you're
you know contracts come up but if you're
the Bengals and you're the Chargers
are you going to pay 230 million dollars
guaranteed to Joe burrow and Justin
Herbert yes those two are by far
guaranteed money yes okay that's where
it's going the quarterback position is
going to be a fully guaranteed position
and there are holding out as long as
they can but I can guarantee that Ryan
but I don't want to guarantee 230
million dollars I'd like to bring him
back to where the other players are I
know you'd like to he's not willing to
do that and he right now is one of the
best quarterbacks in all of the NFL and
that is a league all right here you go
do you got Justin Herbert Joe burrow
Lamar Jackson
give me the order of you're going to pay
230 million dollar guaranteed Joe burrow
Lamar Jackson Justin Herbert okay
but all three in your bank account are
getting 230 million dollar guarantee
yeah they can
capologists general managers they can
figure a way to get it done just listen
to Andrew Brandt uh he's he's helped me
a ton in figuring out how to go about
this where you go and pay your
quarterback a ton of money a huge
portion of what the cap percentage is
and still be able to feel a very
competitive team he's been incredibly
helpful when you've got Lamar who's been
injured the last two years I'm not going
to pay you on what you did I got to pay
you on what we are going to do together
as we move forward I I can't pay them
that kind of well if I'm not going to
give them guaranteed 230 million if you
paid him what he did every time he's
been on the field he's been the best
player in that division you know uh at
the quarterback position when he's been
hurt he's been hurt I don't fault him at
all for not playing at the end of the
year if he wasn't 100 because he went
out and played on his fifth year they
should have done this deal yes they
should have done this deal after year
three but the same thing with the Giants
with Daniel Jones they should have they
should that at all would you have given
Daniel Jones that deal
I wouldn't have but uh
but they were kind of they kind of put
themselves in a tough position they
didn't give them a fifth year option
right he goes out and plays so well that
they get to the the he wins a playoff
game and then he had the Leverage
I don't know how much leverage I don't
know who was bidding against no I I give
him a you know non-exclusive you want to
there you go you want him I'm the old
you're the only other person I've heard
say that I said it too they should have
given the non-exclusive paid him 32.8
and say do it again in Brian dable's
office yes yeah absolutely I'm with you
uh the situation with the Jets what can
the Jets tell Aaron Rodgers what do you
think they told Aaron Rodgers that would
make him go all right I'm gonna be a jet
oh I'm sure they you know you know
clamored to his ego and uh you know
approach the approach the uh you know
the narcissism
um and Nathaniel hackett's there there's
a big I mean do you want Aaron Rodgers
no
no listen to this people all right you
are the New York Jets do you honestly
think you bring in Aaron Rodgers the
team is good enough
you add that piece they LeapFrog Buffalo
they LeapFrog Cincinnati they LeapFrog
Kansas City I'm even gonna throw
Jacksonville and Los Angeles maybe Miami
you think they LeapFrog all those people
because you only get them for a year
you're only going to get them that's why
I don't want him because there you go I
are so on the same page and I never
would have thought that yeah yeah
I think they go after Lamar that's
enough I I think they get on get on that
plane and fly right to Baltimore or down
to Miami where you would take Lamar if
you're the Jets over
Aaron Rodgers I would pay him the what
his I would sign him to his offer sheet
toss over those a couple first round
draft picks and now you got the whole
team that you had there before and you
got a guy for the next five years in his
prime playing in New York where you have
been just absolutely uh anemic at the
quarterback position and I think they're
a year away I I think they're too I
think they're a playoff team but if I'm
making a move I don't want to make a
move that's really a false move that we
have Aaron and then we don't have him
now what do we really have are we back
to Mike White that's why I like Derek
Carr I did too yeah what the hell is
going on that you and I are on the same
page you just haven't had me on in a
long time you and I just started I'm not
uh you know maybe it's my move to
Connecticut we're both Connecticut
people now and so now we think
differently yeah yeah and a few years
ago I never would have thought we'd have
been on the same page nope now we are oh
my Lord
well you're growing up
how cool is this though uh we moved to
Connecticut and Paulie Paulie's little
girls
um Peyton Molly they babysit my little
five-year-old now Macgyver yes it's it
is the best thing in the world because
Paulie was the one that always reached
out to me back when I was struggling so
poor so poorly and we've stayed friends
forever yeah
um and and now we're in this place where
his his little girls are I go to his I
go to his girl's uh little basketball
game and and MacGyver came along I still
think that you got to name your kid
MacGyver how awesome is that and your
wife was fine with it she's the one who
picked it damn
but is he going to be Mac or is he going
to be are you going to be you know hey
his name is MacGyver
um I call him McGee okay you know I it's
MC it's not spelled like MacGyver the TV
show it's spelled
mcgyver so I call him Mick G
um Anna calls him Guyver sometimes
um all right you know some people call
him Mac
um but uh he knows when he's in trouble
he'll get the MacGyver Fitzgerald over
here yeah yeah it's great to see you you
too and I hope your car uh you know is
it's just a just a 15 000 mile service
appointment it just happens to be down
the road so I thought I'd come in the
green room and watch you watch it works
great happy for your success that's uh
Ryan leave joining us on the program